thanks everyone for getting started hold
on one moment and we'll begin in about
ten minutes
you
okay everyone this is Jeremy she playing
with Khan Academy thank you so much for
your patience getting started this
morning or this afternoon depending on
where you're calling it from it's my
extreme privilege introduce you to
Connor Corey is one of the most awesome
teachers that I've met in a long long
time and just someone that I wish was
teaching my own kids because of the
incredible way they goes about engaging
his own students so Connor thank you so
much for being with us today and thank
you for sharing your expertise with a
larger Khan Academy community thank you
it's been great to be here it's been a
pleasure to be invited in absolutely let
me see if I can get your webcam set up
here just go ahead and turn that on if
you can all right we're in business so
again thank you everyone for making time
out of there I know this is week two for
many of us as far as kids running around
while we're trying to serve our students
Connor is in the same boat you have four
kids is that right Connor I do and they
are all at home my wife is distracting
them in the other room right now and so
if you hear her screaming in the
background that's coming from me well
there you go that's a secret to being a
great teacher is having a very
supportive spouse so thank you to her
and thank you to your kids for letting
us steal you away for about half an hour
but I promise to make it super
worthwhile for everyone on the line and
so I want to start with a little bit of
your background as an educator tell us a
little bit about you know how long
you've been teaching what you've been
teaching the students that you serve and
then we'll go from there
this is my 17th year teaching I spent
the first 13 years of my career teaching
in the Philadelphia School District
public schools and we were on a contract
issue for a few years I went back to
school to go into administration and
that's kind of really where I found my
love for curriculum and math more than
administration I around my 14th year I
took a job as a math interventionist
which was kind of a new position and
Centennial school districts but it was
one I thought was needed it was more of
every school has reading specialists
most of the time where students are
pulled out to rebuild a foundation for
literacy but that foundation for math is
sometimes skipped as they go
grade to grade so I was for three years
I spent pulling students for small group
instruction to rebuild their
mathematical foundation and then this
year I went back into the classroom they
teach middle school math she's a pashtun
obviously so I am back as a sixth grade
math teacher the [ __ ] that's awesome so
tell us a little bit about how you been
using Khan Academy IVs kind of CAD me
for about 10 years now I think it came
out of a need more than anything while
in Philadelphia is most you know large
metropolitan school districts we're a
little bit underfunded and some of the
materials that we needed are not
available the class set of books was of
twenty but I had 34 students and three
were kind of 10 years old so you had
numerous wonderful pictures drawn in by
5th graders over the 10 years that
resembled me sometimes but so we had to
find a way also most of my students
weren't on level they were two years
below level maybe some are a little bit
advanced but getting that material
became red tape paper work of well maybe
you have to fill this out because we're
gonna see if there's special education
and it's now they're not special ed
they're just a little behind in
fractions I just need the material Khan
Academy kind of gave me that for free
and I was able to implement almost a
centers based approach like many
literacy teachers already do at the
elementary level and we kind of rotate
our class each day in that way where I
may teach one group of ten students on a
3rd grade level if we're all working on
geometry and then they'll rotate the
work on Khan Academy and then a project
and the third station that has to do
with geometry within the next group it
may be fourth grade and fifth grade
after that and kind of try to hit their
academic level overall for each of them
and we may not get to the third grade
student on a third grade level to a
sixth grade level that year but we will
rebuild the foundation so the vocabulary
makes more sense and they can strive
further rather than just kind of
skipping along and hope they pick it up
very cool so fill those foundations kind
of like Timbo
berg has been talking about in his
mastery of learning webinar yes and I
share the same belief is 10 most the
time we did many things of going back to
kindergarten and starting all the way
over and it's doing fantastic very cool
so and this into the academic side I
think one of the things that any
follower of your Twitter feed which I
shared in the chat a second ago will
notice is like you really bring this joy
and this love of learning to everything
you do in the classroom in normal times
and the best of times
what are your some of your most
successful engagement techniques for
really getting your kids excited about
Khan Academy and more importantly just
learning itself I came to the belief a
long time ago that all kids it doesn't
matter your background or where you're
from they enjoy kind of embarrassing
their teacher seeing their teacher look
like an idiot
doing things that they would not
normally be able to do in a school
building and I figured attaching
memories like that to my classroom was
always the best way I think it came
about like it came out 10 years ago
there before all the fort night dances
and everything like that there was a
dance called the wu-tang but all my
students would just not stop doing and
in the school yard if you look down the
school yard there's 200 kids in circle
dancing and one kid he just walked by
the sharpest pencil he started dancing
and I just like was kidding around and
made fun of them like that's it it's all
you got you better practice before you
go out the schoolyard
he started saying talking trash it's
like you can't do it I'm when you were
born in 2004 you don't know anything
about wu-tang like I got it and then
they all wanted to say it and it was
okay if you all get the 20% I'll go out
and schoolyard and do it and they love
it they worked so hard those next two
weeks or so and then it kind of spiraled
from there a kid had a water balloon in
their desk one day they the many reasons
you want to think a kid would have a
water balloon in his desk um has had to
stop and go what possessed you to think
this is a good idea
yes and then we started talking about
I'll let you throw water balloons at if
you guys get the 30% and those kind of
memories we just started doing crazy
stuff and I've worked with unbelievable
staff over the years but join in and we
just try to get things that they can't
purchase like its certificate so the
more memories that they want to do
that's cool and so what kinds of results
have you got in with this approach like
making yourself say I'll do whatever it
takes to get you to mastery I think you
hit almost every angle of your students
you have the introverted students who
may not want to say they want to sit it
and you have some of the your most
extroverted students that are the ones
screaming and always doing stuff you're
getting all of them to work for a
similar goal which is to embarrass you
or even the other staff members we did
one you wouldn't believe when I was in
Willa Dale for three years I had
unbelievable staff and one time we did a
week it was called a wheel of doom and
we put all the teachers names on it and
they basically whoever one learned storm
for that month lever at the highest
growth that class came up we made an
assembly sixteen teachers come up front
and sit there and chairs and they would
spin this wheel and it would land on
ketchup mustard mayonnaise and let me
just get this teachers face and they had
a blast why 400 kids are in the audience
screaming and excited about math work
they're doing so I think it was things
like that just engage students more and
whether they the learning comes
secondary will always come as long as
they're excited about something I love
that and so obviously those are the best
of times being there physically for the
wheel of doom we are far from the best
of times right now is we can
unfortunately what are you doing with
your students today to drive engagement
in this remote learning environment what
would you recommend from that toolbox
the best practices for everyone else
listening right now I mean I'm go I mean
tempting always trying new things I'm
attempting to do similar things with
just getting the students excited I
think a lot of teachers are starting to
run into federal guidelines of online
learning I think that's becoming a
struggle but I've used flipgrid
throughout the year to communicate and
now we're using kind of zoom meetings to
say just to get in touch with your
students and do things not work that's
required but voluntary for something to
do your students miss you they do I miss
them and right now we're doing a
tick-tock
because I know that's everything my
students are into right now so I put out
a few assignments on Khan Academy I said
it's voluntary if you would like to join
in tell me and I put them in a class I
put five assignments up for the week if
they finish those assignments my
daughter and I will do the flip the
switch challenge for tick-tock and then
send it to them through flip read which
sends its own through zoom or something
like that but just to keep them engaged
I send riddled math riddles to them
through there just to kind of get them
through that everything's okay
everything didn't totally stop because I
think a lot of kids are scared right now
they're looking at adults for answers
and we don't have so we're just trying
to I think all get through this together
that's cool so even though it does feel
like the world is topsy-turvy you're
still the same mr. Kouri are still
providing that same level of excitement
and motivation even if it can't be with
them in person
we're hoping to we're gonna actually try
to get some of the parents involved next
week and see if they will participate in
the same thing since they're at home
with them and maybe has kids I think we
were gonna do a five refrigerate five
thing blender five things in your fridge
you can put in a blender and that parent
has to drink it try to get the kids
involved as parents about for something
fun to do new learning going on but we
can all use the review and we just need
maybe a couple lasts throughout it yeah
and that's actually interesting question
so like I think a lot of educators are
now trying to figure out do I take this
time as if it's normal school time quote
unquote
and try to push forward with my content
or do I go into that review mode and
sort of keep them you know stabilizing
those foundations filling those gaps
rather than pushing forward any thoughts
on that sort of conundrum I always think
right now is a burr of you time I am
looking at it as yes I'm teaching sixth
grade students but they can all review
fourth grade content things they enjoy
doing or something maybe they liked from
years in the past many times like in
literacy if a child's constantly reading
you don't care if the book the reading
that they're interested in is below
level but for math there's always this
different we have to push
them and push them along grade level and
never skip a beat I think this is more
of a let's try to have some fun we don't
want to most parents do not know what
slope-intercept form is or how to graph
systems of equations so if you're
applying that but you're not able to
teach it and you're signing those things
that becomes a struggle for parents and
I think that's kind of the opposite
effect as they're already stressed out
enough cool well lots of things you've
already shared and answer some of the
most common questions we've received so
teachers were asking about how do you
get students working at the appropriate
level for their need you're talking
about even going back a couple of grades
if that's where the gaps are you can do
that with Khan Academy take it you're
asking about how do you form a virtual
sense of community and it sounds like
you're doing that by getting all the
students working towards a common goal
using a platform like flipgrid
to engage not just the students but
their parents as well it's in a really
visual and exciting way what about this
question though one of the teachers
asked how can I get kids who don't even
engage face-to-face even those best of
times to actually engage online when
things are way harder I mean knowing
your students is always the one of the
largest things you have to learn in the
beginning of the year I am always
surprised that how some of my
introverted students are some of my
students that don't engage and raise
their hand and answer questions how well
online tools have worked to let me know
their understanding without them telling
me to gain a perspective of if they're
getting a concept that I'm teaching and
Khan Academy has always done that with
the assignments and watching them grow
where they don't have to be you know
maybe they're a little bit shy and they
don't want to be the one that asked that
question that they don't know what this
word means but when you see that they're
not achieving on something that you know
they understand it can be as simple as
just going over next to them and asking
them like what's wrong it's you see
things like flipper and kids love making
videos and I have one student who is
very shy
not talk a lot to demean his friends he
talks the other kids but won't engage me
very much in class once we started using
Flickr
he's whole persona changed when I saw
his first video is mr. stache nice all
very outgoing and this and that and all
the other kids saw it and they started
wanting to be in his group to make the
next video and now he runs mr. stache
productions but he's still that same kid
in class that won't raise his hand that
won't like you know put himself out
there but as soon as he is able to make
these videos so I found it has the most
opposite effect at times and everything
so maybe that's almost the silver lining
of the times you find ourselves in is
because it's not all real time and it's
not all live in the classroom those
students who need a little more time on
their own to process sort of share what
they want to communicate now have that
time in this asynchronous learning
whether it's creating a flip group video
responding to a con assignment on your
own time students had that space it
sounds like yeah and I think that's
always been a significant advantage with
Khan Academy that they have the time to
do the assignments again to try it more
than one time to stop and take a hint or
to stop and watch a video and the whole
class isn't waiting for you if you're
not getting a concept or you're not
moving on with nothing else to do
there's always something that's right at
your level that you can kind of take
time to reflect and think about hey cool
so a couple final questions then we'll
open up for live questions from the
audience how can I help students persist
when times are tough you have talked a
lot about growth mindset and about grit
in the last couple years especially in
this moment of crisis how do we help
students get through this I mean I think
it's important to realize that we are
all going through something right now
this isn't just going to affect small
parts of our country or our world I
think is really reaching out to your
students whether it's through a zoom
meeting or just letting them know that
you're still there is so hugely
important because some everyone thinks
everybody's at home but many parents are
still reporting to work and some of our
medical staff and everything or at work
large amounts of the day children are
still at home by themselves looking for
something I think it's important to help
lead your families and your as a teacher
in those ways it's it's gonna be tough
but I think just keeping an open line of
communication is the number one thing
that we can do as educators right now
and allow students to ask questions and
allow them to try to persist but pride
obviously with growth mindset we've
taught that throughout the year
and continuing to do that but also using
a lot of review concepts that are just
keeping them going rather than
struggling on the room that's cool I'm
so powerful um I have to give a shout
out to this van Driessen in South Dakota
who sent me a video she created it for
her fifth-grade class this morning and
she just said the simple words I'm
thinking about you
I know from my own daughter's experience
if you hear that from the most
meaningful educator in your life that's
powerful even when times are tough so
just keeping that communication open and
so huge and then one last question that
came up quite a bit was okay again we're
talking about students who are all sort
of facing major challenges and we're
facing even bigger ones on top of that
if you want to support their special
education students in the middle of this
crisis any words of wisdom for how to
serve that audience really really well I
think this is an issue that many
educators are facing at the moment and
it obviously depends on a child's IEP
and some of the federal walls that are
coming into play with districts trying
to go to virtual learning for the next
month and if they're abiding by all
these laws for myself and my own
experience I have students in my class
with IEP s I always have my entire
career I never really changed what I'm
doing for one specific kid I changed the
weight or act with certain students and
the materials I give certain students
and the way they can kind of participate
and how I can highlight them here but
many of my students that have an IEP
they are perfectly producing in math
class they are participating
I kind of just always like I would do
anything else I value the student I know
who they are and know what kind of
pushes them and I try to get into it
that way but right now with students
that do have an IEP I think there are
districts one teachers to be extremely
careful not requiring any work for
almost any of their students as a grade
until we kind of get some of this
figured out I mean obviously we want to
make sure we're hitting all our students
but I think our teachers are doing that
I don't know that our teachers are
looking and saying well I can only teach
to this group and I can't teach to my
other students that may have a learning
disability I think we're just all in it
together trying to figure out how we can
engage everybody and keep an online
classroom going hey let me open it up to
questions from the audience here we've
got a bunch coming in I want to start
with a great one from Lindsay so Lindsay
says hey Connor this has been awesome
but what kind of goals or targets do you
set for your students do you focus them
on mastering a skill getting to grade
level how do you keep them from just
grinding toward a goal and actually
feeling a sense of progress
I used personalized goal-setting for now
seven years with my students I mean I
believe it's the most effective way and
we celebrate that goal-setting
throughout the process so I have
students that are on three years of
different levels so well they would all
they have these little Lego guys that
you know for mastery on Khan Academy
what we print those out and the kids
write their name on them and their goal
may say I want to get the 45 percent in
third grade and they sit with that kid
and I put it I hang it up on the wall
and the next student maybe I want to get
this 60% on fifth grade and it's usually
about 15% higher than where ever they
are but for the one to move on its fifth
grade it's going to take the same amount
of effort for the third one the students
don't third grade level to move his
score so we've really focused these
goals on the child's care and academic
level and how much effort it would take
them to move up and the majority of time
those goals are not
great level they are a little bit below
some are a little bit above but anytime
a child hits a goal we usually have
something and if you don't have anything
kids love like okay you can take
whatever is in my desk that you find
that you want that you'd be surprised
the crap that's in your desk and the
things that a kid will take a watch that
was on the floor two years ago it will
be stickers for like kindergarten and
they're like yeah I shouldn't throw
these out and you just throw me or dads
go go through your desk and I think it's
the coolest thing ever we did these we
have these like little bracelets I've
been doing these for years there you can
buy hundreds of them for you know $20
and they just they start to collect
different ones every time they set a
goal but it's small goals over and over
and over to eventually get towards
mastery but I think setting grade level
mastery for all of your students is just
it's unrealistic and there's no need to
set unrealistic goals for your kids
because they're not going to be able to
succeed so what's really the point if
you know them give them the proper level
let them hit small steps along the way
and they start to develop that growth
mindset and the kids don't really care
what level they're learning on I love
how much of your advice is just rooted
in knowing your students if you know
they're gonna be motivated by something
that's tangible attainable then give
them that
don't try to sort of set the bar way too
high and intimidate them make them feel
good about their progress and I'm gonna
want to do it again um so how many
questions are coming in about flipgrid
they're saying what does this flipgrid
what is it all about can you explain a
little bit more there Connor I started
Flickr it's unbelievable it's a free
resource I started to use it heavily
this year I began last year but it's the
end of the year a new platform I'm like
okay maybe next year I started it
basically you create a video for
yourself yeah there's the front you
create a video for yourself and for your
students and they are it's almost like
its own social media that video will go
out to York your students your students
are now able to respond to that video
and you could just do a topic such as
like hey I just want to say hi do you
guys want everyone to say hello back see
what you're missing about school
and there is things to help all along
the way to get you started but we've
used it heavily for our explaining math
this year where we have students create
videos on a mathematical topic of order
of operations okay what do we do first
and they'll make lifts different scenes
in different movies like weed around
Christmas we did what does it mean that
had something 20% off and kids were
making their backgrounds of being in a
store or paying for something that's 20%
off but they were able to explain to me
what those concepts were about and what
act how they apply in the real world and
that gave me more than any test could
ever give me it showed me well they were
actually understanding each part of this
process and I think and you're able to
respond to their videos the other kids
in the class leave what's called a vibe
and they're able to respond so it forms
a sense of community and then any kind
of we have a mixtape that has all our
top videos from all three classes the
best ones and the kids I mean we vote on
the videos who came up with the most
creative but it's an unbelievable
program and it's 100% free
I would suggest they check it out like
everything just kind of start small say
if you can get things started with Khan
Academy start small I think all these
platforms for educators and parents it's
kind of like when you get a new phone
you get it and you're like I just want
to send the funny picture my friend I
don't need to sign up my Google Cloud I
just and you're trying to figure it out
but then day after day literally a
little bit after a little bit it starts
to make sense and become easier and then
you start to see the value of all the
things you actually have on your phone I
think if we start technology that way in
this online learning platform that's
going to continue for the next few weeks
I think that's our best option very cool
and then denise has a question which is
basically you mention the federal
regulations and federal device was just
coming down can you talk a little bit
more about that for educators who have
not heard about what's being shared at
that national level national level you
like fate laws that are basically you
have to ensure that every
it has the same access to education and
if you're trying to do online learning
they're students that maybe you don't
have the internet at home or maybe they
don't have a device the only device they
have is a parents phone it's going to
work so by I think by districts pushing
out a platform of we're going to
continue school without addressing those
needs first and all the needs that are
in that child's IEP of differentiated
learning having an aid having someone
else to explain I think we have a lot of
issues where districts are nervous are
they providing for every child and that
always is the number one thing you can't
exclude a certain amount of children
because it's not convenient right now so
there's a lot of I guess but federal
laws of put in place for a good reason
and now in this unprecedented time
people are like I don't know if I can
get around this because am I then not
educating every child am i providing
what's been stated by law that I have to
do to educate this person but I think
the lack of devices and the lack of
Internet access and different things is
a big issue that many people are seeing
great I'm gonna throw down the gauntlet
for you a little bit here Connor I'm
gonna stretch your engagement abilities
some high school teachers have been
saying this is awesome but awesome for
middle schoolers awesome for elementary
students I've got eleven and twelfth
graders how am I gonna keep them engaged
when they're already so cynical to begin
with on top of that they have so much
else on their shoulders these days
middle school students are just as
cynical I think high school kids are
just like the older middle school kids
they think they're too cool for
everything they think they're just kind
of going through the motions but they're
worried about what they look like what
this person thinks what's going on on
social media they would find it just as
funny and it does if you did stupid
things in your class with them if you
did he ticked I danced with your whole
class if you did certain things
that they're interested in they you find
ridiculous but to them it's like all
right well I've to thing to classes I
have homeworks for which one were going
to do it for this I'm not gonna do for
vocable so you want to be the teacher
that they'll do your homework for you or
they'll do go the extra step for you and
I think again like it's knowing your
students you may have one class that you
could do one thing with and you may have
another class that you can but it's
always will just always be willing to
try new things and not embarrass
yourself nothing's gonna change if you
continually stay the same so if you're
uncomfortable in what you're doing all
the time I think that's a positive thing
dad I'll just throw a couple ideas that
I've heard recently for the high school
set I know in a lot of ways they face
the sort of most daunting challenges
because so much of their expected life
over the next few months is on hold now
whether it's taking the SAT taking the
ApS graduation college decisions all
this stuff is supposed to be happening
and now it's frozen what could you do to
fill that void could you host their
virtual prom could you take a page out
of your scans playbook yeah I'm doing
these senior nights every night on
SportsCenter shouting out the high
school seniors who would have been
getting fed and otherwise could you sort
of give it a chance and really let your
seniors shine even during this really
difficult moment so if there's some way
you can bring that sense of normalcy its
sense of tradition into this virtual
world I think you'll be a superstar on
in their eyes no matter how cynical they
are okay so let's see here I think we
have time for maybe one or two questions
and so I think the biggest question that
I've got in from a lot of teachers at
this point is how do you altimeter
students at different levels given that
everything we've been talking about in
terms of like zoom or whatever feels
like it's just like okay one teacher and
all the students in a big lecture
environment how do you continue to sort
of differentiate and make sure each to
each student feels heard and respected
in this time my feet for the leveling
for myself I know most of my students
level I know where I'm kind of teaching
them and whatever topic it is maybe I
assign to my one group of ten stood
the remediated foundational skills and
my hire group maybe the intense word
problems but those skills all count
towards the same thing as our overall
goal of this stupid TED talk video I'm
going to create probably today but
having that knowing your students and
having them all each doing different
things you're also able like I said with
flipgrid give them a chance to ask
questions if you're on a virtual
classroom with zoom and you're saying
okay submit your questions here and then
you can send that video out just to the
students that maybe need a little bit of
assistance with that but I think it's
important to try to recognize all your
students too that are working at home
that are putting in the extra effort but
really just constant communication is
gonna be your number one thing to see
how kids are doing to see why maybe
these 10-15 kids haven't logged on yet
or haven't done anything is there an
issue because maybe there is and as
teachers we're always looking for that
to see how we can help in that anyway
cool well I think if anyone wants
inspiration as we sign off here I would
strongly encourage you to check out
Connors Twitter feed he's at twitter.com
slash see Cory 223 and as you can see
here he's got lots of examples of
engaging his students engaging his own
selves in at home with cool crafts and
activities and this gives you a sense of
what's possible with getting students
really excited about learning even in
this difficult environment we find
ourselves in so definitely follow Connor
check out his ideas and keep your
questions coming I didn't get a chance
to get to everyone
we'll definitely be doing more sessions
like this and so if you have other ideas
or questions for Connor or for Khan
Academy please submit those in the
survey that will follow that being said
any last words of wisdom for the
audience Connor no I want to say thank
you for tuning in and thank you over at
Khan Academy in the next you know few
weeks just enjoy the time with your
family you're not gonna be stuck with
them
this large of a period for many years I
would say just try not to get on each
other's nerves my wife asked me if I had
to chew my that the other day so I think
we've been in close quarters for a lot
but just try to enjoy the time I don't
think we're gonna get it back and the
more questions you ask about what's
gonna happen next year with education
the more the less answers you're gonna
get so kind of focus on your family
focus on you know your loved ones now
and what we can do together call I can't
think of a better message to end on that
one so thank you all for making time out
of your days
make it a Connor for sharing your
incredible expertise and here's wishing
you all a wonderful week thank you so
much
you